let's open it up sure let's let's lead
the way so this is this is this is
what's called the uh the hot pack so
we're gonna do this last okay okay um
now the key with this card is tell me
what why why is it called a hot pack
because this has this is a hobby
exclusive
and it has a guaranteed called a an x
factor in here which is one of those
rare cards guaranteed guaranteed there's
one guaranteed x factor in this box
so what we're looking at and um
with these cards they are um let me move
this over here there we go i should have
brought a um i should have brought a mat
notice how he carefully opens the pack
yes in fact
his hands are
not dirty okay here we go i want to see
who i get okay so we have
and these you gotta be careful not to
touch you get cory mcgetty we able to
see this by the way if you can yeah if
you can put the camera uh
can you guys zoom in one of the cameras
john if you want to come in here or
george so we can zoom it in okay
cory mcgetty okay
i remember him steve francis okay if you
franchise yeah
kurt thomas
miami heat
checklist we don't want that
what is that card you say it's a
checklist this is not okay
and mike's sweetness okay
no georgetown
what i will tell you is people gonna say
oh my god you got fingerprints um
some people open up cards with gloves
you can damage the i find you can damage
the card that way because you don't have
the real feel and what people do is they
can take a microfiber and just clean a
fingerprint off it and anytime you any
time you send a card out to get grading
if you're not taking a a
a microfiber and touching the card to
make sure you're removing your
fingerprints you're downgrading your
grade now again there's only five cards
per pack there's only five cards per
pack
excuse me four cards 24 packs per box
four cards per pack i got to tell you
the cards are cooler than i remember
they're like almost risen a little bit
we got here matt harpering
jalen rose
jaylen rose 81.
you know what's 81. pavlovic what's 81.
kobe scored 81. scored
travis hanson okay travis hansen i don't
remember that guy at all
here we go
this box so some of these cards are just
whatever some dude who never made it
whatsoever and then you got guys like
steve francis who's arguably a hall of
famer yes you got a lot of rookies and
also these guys all made it they're all
in the nba mm-hmm um okay
so we got oh is this able to show it all
if you can't zoom in
yeah we got jorge on the case for his
mom we're gonna brent barry who was one
of the greatest fantasy players of all
time because he had amazing percentages
wow he won the dunk contest yeah bobby
jackson
great point guard minnesota's banks
marcus banks come on unlv we need a
lebron out of this box yeah we do ken
okay well we we just pulled a good
rookie because i saw the back okay okay
so we have a um we have a better rookie
um it'll be the last card let's hope
there's more in this
pack model definitely definitely a
future hall of famer in the back of this
pack
you know ginobili no no no no no no who
do we got there no that is ginobili he's
definitely i mean he's i think he's
genuinely he just got it
eddie curry
bust
richard hamilton reparation
hall of famer
he lives right across the street from us
oh you know it's serious ken just busted
out that plastic covering and what do
you got there ken
a chrome
carmelo anthony wow
you've got the caramel anthony rookie
card so you can put that right in the
plastic yep absolutely
shout out to you buddy this way you guys
won't get your fingerprints on it what's
something like this go for um yeah
it's it's it's not a thousand dollar
card but at least at least at least it's
three hundred dollars two hundred
dollars yeah so a rookie mellow
nuggets
rookie in the back of this one not the
rookie i want to see
okay we got latrell spreewell
spreewell
joke his coach out here the first thing
i thought about quran butler
quran
assistant coach of the year murphy and i
gotta look at these carefully just to
make sure i'm not skipping over a uh
refractor i probably have already
because the refractors they're the same
front but they're just shiny
so and all these cards are kind of shiny
so again is this basically what you did
with drake this is exactly what i did
with drake yes now the difference with
the 86 flair box is because they were
all
well-known players mostly
you um
you had a lot of cards that everybody
wants to get
andre miller
and they also only had 132 cards in the
in the set this is a much larger set
andre miller very underrated point guard
jason yeah he was actually pretty good
terry the jet
jarvis hayes
okay
come on
that's just looking for a dennis rodman
rookie card that's that well that would
be 1988. see he knows
88 same year as pippen i believe right
that flier yep exactly one set wally
zerbiak
molly wally's kwame brown talk about
yours
great podcaster
tyler this one's for you ty we gotta get
kwame on the scene
he's he's blown up by the way he has
blown up what is like if you two years
ago his card would have been irrelevant
now who was he fighting with was it um
he was getting into it with uh a
commentator like matt barnes and uh
all the smoke pods steven a smith was
that the one who was oh it was stephen
yes it was stephanie smith you're right
okay
you're right well who doesn't have beef
with stephen a smith okay so we have so
you can see right here we have a
refractor you can see the difference yep
yep okay so let's hope it's somebody
who's good because if it is that'll pay
for the box eric snow
nope eric's kenny hardaway yeah second
best player
to penny
[Music]
what do we got what do we got oh we have
a really good card
we have a tracy mcgrady game worn
sick t-mac okay so let's get that tracy
mcgrady game worn jersey yes you have uh
it's a
25
refractor okay so we pulled
the first one is i've actually pulled a
2003 chrome can you um can you uh zoom
it in it's uh
see if you're on it or not
do i gotta tilt it tracy mcgrady
that's the angle right there if you got
it that's the camera okay you see it or
not
okay good yeah they can see the back let
me show the back you can see where it's
got the congratulations and you got the
number 25. it's one out of 25 yes
so what's something like that go for
i couldn't even quote this off the top
of my head so it's i've never um
i know there's a million dollars yeah no
no i would i wish i would
but it's one in 25 years
okay
so that's good let me
put this in here too
t-mac
could have been going down as one of the
best players ever if he avoided those
five out of 25. that's so good so that's
a good one
and then we got the last one is uh josh
moore
okay never even heard of him all right
we got team mac here
oh wow it's that little piece of his
jersey in the card it's actually pretty
dope yep
game worn shorts
so they cut off a little piece of his
shorts and they put in the cards
yeah ken i remember back in the day when
i was growing up in the 1920s it came
with gum please god be good here you go
pbd all right let's see what we got here
oh crap
okay we got a really really really good
card but not of a really good player
gary payton
okay gary pate what do you mean no no no
no no no no no we got so earnest would
be 1990 or no 92 i believe right uh
peyton i think would probably i think
peyton is that i think 90 91. yeah uh
derrick coleman same year as uh coleman
i believe zarunis ogaskus so this is
what's known as a black
refractor it is one of the holy grail
cards
if this were lebron we'd have a half a
million dollar card right now who's that
whose card is that this is mike miller
three-point specialist for the heat yeah
memphis grid now if you can even
something like that is that in the few
thousands or no um i only if it's a 10
yes wow so this is um limited to 500
but the black refractors are very very
tough
because it's because of the border to
get you know really high grade so this
one is definitely
this one's perfect
that's what i was supposed to mike
miller mike miller was uh he won it for
the year game seven okay now uh ken if
you could somehow pull an rv to sabonis
the best passing big man of all time
i would love that who was a four who
would that go to was that you and i or
yes yeah
so when you open these cards with drake
and every first card had the stick of
gum on it how much how many cards are
actually high value cards that you can't
get the gum off of um luckily with drake
we had dude there was none on a jordan
and none on any of the key rookie cards
um they don't do the gum anymore right
no they don't do gum anymore luckily but
they used to why did they put the gum in
there it was because the top started as
a gum company it was bazooka you know
bazooka joe joe great gum yao ming that
would be a good card if it was a
refractor
nanae
then may yeah just like elvis one name
only that's right and maurice williams
nuggets okay you remember in the name oh
william yeah you're worse than that
i'll do one here yeah you want to do one
or two yeah let's do it all right tyler
do you want to do one
i'm interested in that all right let's
see what we got here
pvd
okay
so the way you're doing it is
so i go like this
i take it up top
i hold the edges and i just pull it out
so that it can go like that and then
once i get once i get a seam
i just carefully peel out
take it at the top
can you grab a scissors
do you want me to um want me to start
the packs for you guys i would love for
you to do that i could see myself
pulling this apart and butchering it pbd
would you send that to to ken
if that if that has my arvida sabonis
card in there i'm running out the studio
ken
nick van axel oh yeah six point plays so
much with the lakers before kobe it was
nicknamed van axel yes yep
i got a dejuan wagner
do you remember the one right yeah of
course came out of high school i believe
keith vanderbilt's son is the is the
number one number one high school player
in the country really point guard yep
wow
outlaw
he played for um adam let's see your
luck adam here we go
i know this guy
duncan's rookie is what year huh what's
what years duncan 99 duncan is uh is
92.99 is
1997. seven or eight 97. he won he won
with uh david robinson yes in 99. that's
something i got dropped hold on hold on
i don't know what just happened here
what but i got a kobe okay
i got a kobe bat there we go this is for
you pbd so let's get this let's get what
do we do with there i just pulled a
goldie brian
is that a draco worth anything or no
no that's so cool put it in here put the
kobe in here too you're going in you see
this
i just got a kobe
pat because i love you so much i'm
giving you my kobe card unbelievable
please go serbian here thank you
i got jamal mashburn who i just saw at
the heat game the other day good for you
man
yeah
what what story you know about jamal
mashburn
i don't know he was doing some shady
stuff in kentucky what do you got
jamal manchester remember the three j's
jason kidd jamal mashberg jimmy jackson
jimmy jackson yeah that's right jackson
i got brian grant
and a very underrated big man zaza
pachulia remember zaza did brian grant
play with is that his brother or no no
right because uh you're thinking of
harvey grant harvey no brian grant was a
heat guy with dreads
uh i think he said run into some health
issues recently
uh but he got traded with lamar odom
to the lakers
i got a richard davis
car malone car malone matt harping
harp ring and then i got a rookie
no i don't think that is john stephenson
here you go
we've got here
that kobe card small mesh for brian
grant
ken i appreciate you um
opening up the
cards by the way the only tendency below
graphic the only time i open up plastic
stuff i guess if i'm opening up a condom
so this is uh
that's my old days you're sorry guys use
protection that's all i'm saying
reggie miller
oh i got a uh refractor
not a great guy but
his refractor i'll show you guys how you
can tell the uh
difference
sean marion i mean you got it the matrix
by the way i i will say this i'm feeling
very childlike right now this is like a
cool feeling
like i haven't done this stuff and let
me see how you can tell so 30 years
you have to notice that this chrome is a
the chrome's a little dull here and it's
a little bright here and you look at the
back and you see the bottom left if you
see 160 it's a refractor
if you see what color like these or it's
not the color it's got to say number 160
no no no no it's got to be shiny so you
really have to be able to see it so i
probably should look at your guys cards
when you're done to see if you passed
over any uh see if you passed over any
refraction i think this one might be a
refractor there's mike dunleavy junior
shout out to the uh
dunleavy family this one seems a little
uh
and what's the big deal with refractors
somebody's trying to collect the set and
they need to have total refractors right
getting refractor sets are like is
highly expensive and virtually
impossible checklist
now what are these checklists for us uh
so you see you know who's in the set
no this is not a refractor okay
so these are all 0.304 these are all
three not rookies though just they
played in the league yes they were in
the league in 0304
some of these guys antonio mcdice
damn david west oh
come on where are you lebron
i'm going to put that here
yes i did okay nowitzki
so if there's ken if there's one
player in the league
not like a hall of famer not like an mj
lebron but like a young up-and-comer
who's maybe been in the league for the
last two three years and you can get
your hands on his rookie card who would
it be
you're talking like a luca is it a trey
young john miranda look
obviously
obviously john morant is doing amazing
his cards have gone up luca is uh doing
amazing um his cards have are already up
there i mean luca has a lot of
expectations built into his into his
card prices but he
you know he certainly
he certainly can dominate the dominate
the league i think trey has come off a
little bit this year
um you know i i like um i think tatum is
you know
is really
might be undervalued the guy i'm going
to mention somebody is going to be a
home buddy um but i think is really
undervalued and that is uh joel embiid
my god um giannis
certainly look what if he honest wins uh
four championships and five mvps so he's
got one championship he's got two mvps
it looked like embiid was going to win
the mvp this year now it's probably a
toss-up between embiid and and uh
yannick
you know yeah yoke yokish as well jokic
is um he's an interesting guy yeah he's
um he does not have the type of game
that inspires collectors
yeah he's the he's the reigning mvp he
is the reigning mvp but there are there
are some players who are amazing players
but are underpriced like for example
james harden people don't love buying
james harden um cards i think james
harden is you know
drastically undervalued for what he
accomplished he's got to win the
championship to get that respect yeah
exactly i don't know do you think
giannis can win a championship according
to tom zenner he'll never win one i
think
yeah
by the way
i think giannis is that anything it's
nothing over there no nothing over there
okay so we got about three more packs
left we got yeah we got
three more and then we've got we got
three more and then we've got the the
money pack thanks john let's see what we
got here
let's see what we got here ken thanks
for making me feel like a child again i
appreciate it buddy okay i get a pretty
good rookie in the back let's hope it's
a refractor
it's not now again how old is your son
my son is eight so
is there anything more in life that you
love just opening up cards with your son
oh sorry it's great it's great you do
this with dylan or tico
pbd yeah i would do a j they they they
like uh uh pokemon cards see that's like
what ken was saying another refractor
but paul is really into baseball and uh
that's your son baseball and basketball
yeah yeah so i am i'm remarried so i
have a 25 year old daughter and a 22
year old daughter who in total okay so
tell me what this is you may want to
look at this okay
oh no look at this what this is
oh there you go we got it what do we got
i pulled the lebron we got the lebron
okay
congratulations
this is it this is what we wanted
nicely done pvd so and right behind it
look what's right behind it though ken
that's what you got to see what's behind
it
whoa
oh
wow oh he reaches for the glasses you
know it's legit
he's got the carmilla rookie refractor
this is sick dude this this was the hot
spot so pat pulled out the hot pack yes
pat congratulations
so there's that
this is a carmelo refractor rookie yes
yeah
i don't know i just pulled the boris d
out guys i don't know
okay
french connection pretty decent defender
though this is really good very
versatile i'm very proud that we got
these two cards
way to go so this is it fair to say that
that lebron card just paid for the pack
yeah yeah yeah way to go pbd yes
there's a carmilla
let's see what we got we got
desmond mason oh i got something good
coming up scotty pippen
i got a chris bosh rookie
chris bosh is also uh responsible
yeah that was a by the way oh three
three they call it one of the best if
not the best right yep correct
oh three right there and you weighed
here we go
dark on
oh i militia pulled maybe the best
looking guy in nba history
you guys know who sam casella is of
course absolute stud
doesn't look like an alien at all
you are too funny
tim thomas oh
damn okay so we have
it is jason
richardson x factor jay rich
what a dunker how many how many dunk
contests did he went to
so this is what's called an x factor you
look at it you can see
i'll pass it down limited to 220. but
they put it in the uh holders back in
the day
so that you would um
not get the car damaged
when he when he came out i mean people
thought he was going to be a bigger star
than uh
this guy had this guy had the an
interesting game yeah
he could jump through the roof he just
couldn't want to see if any of these are
before we set them aside yep okay
take a peek
25 000 auto box huh
interesting
so now to get these cards graded it's
going to take us how long
um
i can get them graded pretty quickly
okay i i know somebody can know somebody
so i do just give them to you to get
them graded we can take care of that
food perfect if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]
you